Let's get started. Good morning, everyone.
Welcome to this session at
AACR 26. Today's session is
Agentic AI as the Oncologist: Clinical Decision
Support and Human AI Collaboration.
My name is Renato Umeton. I'm the Vice President of Data Sciences and Chief of
AI for St. Jude Children's Research Hospital.
And today we're going to explore this session with two
giants, one from academia, one from industry.
The reason why in picking the speakers, we decided to structure it
this way is because personally, if you have known me, if you have
worked with me, I am very opportunistic as of where the solution
comes from, right? I'm married to the outcome.
I'm married to seeing a patient outcome improvement, patient
experience improving, clinician experience improving.
Improving our healthcare systems, right? Optimizing cost.
And AI is something that is now
ubiquitous among
all of us, our lives, and in healthcare is
particularly impactful. Our first speaker,
I'm very pleased to introduce Dr. Dorin
Comaniciu, Senior Vice President and Chief
Expert for Healthcare AI at Siemens
Healthineers. His work in computational imaging
and machine learning has translated into a broad
portfolio of clinical products across diagnostic
imaging, image-guided therapy, precision medicine.
He's an elected member of the National Academy of Engineering,
National Academy of Medicine, the Romanian Academy, and a fellow of
IEEE, ACM, and MICCAI Society. He holds the IEEE
Longuet-Higgins Prize for fundamental contribution to computer vision
and a honorary doctor from Friedrich-Alexander
University. With over 550 granted
patents, 350 peer reviews manuscript, and
bringing the perspective of a leading biomedical company
that many of us trust already in our hospitals,
especially within radiology and beyond, I look forward to
what he'll share with us. And thank you very much for joining us,
Dr. Comaniciu. The floor is yours.
Thank you so much for the kind introduction, and especially thank you so much
for coming here to listen to us in this beautiful
San Diego morning. So,
today I will speak about agentic AI in radiation oncology from imaging
to therapy. I'm coming obviously from Siemens Healthineers, and all the
disclosures are that I'm
employed by Siemens Healthineers.
So a couple of words about our
company.
We have in the world something like
300-- I'm sorry, 700,000
equipment
in
the world. So covering everything from
imaging, CT, MR, X-ray, nuclear
medicine, and
including also laboratory diagnostics
and also moving to therapy like interventional oncology,
but also radiation therapy. A couple of years ago, we acquired
Varian, and today we're number one in radiation oncology.
So we see a lot of our focus is on
non-communicable diseases such as neurodegenerative,
cardiovascular, stroke, and the focus of today,
cancer. Now, these devices that we have in the world have
something like
300,000 patient touch points per hour.
So think about during my talk, about 20 minutes, more than
100,000 patient touch points. This gives us a lot of
purpose in what we do.
And
each time, say, colleagues are joining us in the
R&D,
it's very inspiring that actually after so much
work in the school, PhDs and so on and so forth,
ultimately you have an opportunity to give something back, right?
So now,
the base of what we do is very much related to
healthcare AI, and I'm a strong believer that healthcare AI is
perhaps one of the few technologies that has the
potential to make healthcare more efficient,
more effective, but also to expand care to
many people in need.
So you can see here a
simple picture of healthcare AI,
the way we see it from our portfolio.
So our focus is to make imaging
faster and better, what we call patient to image, and
to help interpretation of images in what we call
image to report and plan. And then how to use that
information in order to plan and deliver the therapy.
Now, in the space of healthcare AI, we've been working for quite a bit of
time. We have today more than 100
AI-powered medical devices approved in the US.
We're also innovation leader in this space in AI for MedTech
with quite a number of patents and intellectual property.
I'm responsible for the healthcare AI centers
of Siemens Healthineers. So you see here we have-- I'm coming from
Princeton, New Jersey, and we have a presence in Germany, Eastern
Europe, India, China, and we're currently
building in
Canada, in Alberta.Now, what
differentiates us is what we call a global
healthcare AI factory. For more than actually 10 years,
we're building, improving the factory.
We have supercomputers. You can see here we have more than
one exaflop computational power.
We run more than 1,800 deep learning trainings per day,
and everything is sitting on a very large database.
And the algorithms that are coming from there are
maturing day by day and being translated into our
businesses and following regulatory approvals.
I want to show you one example. So,
actually, four years ago, we published a first paper showing
a foundation model from 100 million
medical images. What you see in front of you, this is learning from half
a billion medical images.
And pretty much you need a lot of compute power, a lot of
data to build these models. Now, if you really think
how much time would be to look at these images
10 seconds at a time, you need something like 150 years.
So these models constitute the base for what we do in terms
of developing the products.
And today, for example, we're training with the next generation with more than
one billion.
So now,
why are we all here? We're here to enhance and
improve the patient experience. And especially
my talk today will be focused on
efficiency. We all know that every 40 weeks of delay in
cancer treatment can increase mortality by 10%.
And the reality is that everything in oncology needs more
efficiency, needs more effectiveness, and again, as I
said, to expand care.
Now, I would like to go back and
think about how we can formalize
everything that's happening today in treatment, in
therapy. Ultimately, you see everything is about
controlling the evolution of a physical biological system,
right? So now with this, I'm going back to some old theories,
actually,
starting with a control theory in the
1940s, 1950s.
Ultimately, to be able to
manage disease, everything reduces to controlling the
evolution of a biological system.
Now, the challenge is that such systems are not
observable.
The state is
partially observable due to the complexity.
So, there is this POMDP, partially observable
Markov decision process that is coming from many years
ago, and in the sense that the agent cannot directly
observe the underlying physical state. Yeah?
So now, you see,
in trying to manage the evolution of
such system, there are a couple of well-defined steps in
the sense that you have the perception, and then from the measurements that you
get from the system, you have a belief model in
building what we call patient state or the system state.
What
the clinician, what we believe is the current state of the system.
And then you have a disease progression model, and based on that, there is a
policy defined and
what we call treatment planning, and then going to plan and control.
Right? So now making more specific, when you put the patient
in the center, then
the patient, again, is only partially observable.
The patient has a very high complexity at a
molecular, cellular, organ, functional level, and everything is so
dynamic, right?
So now,
again, we have the topic of sensing, we have the patient state estimation, the
disease progression model, the therapy planning and therapy.
And I believe it's always very important to keep everything in a context.
We're dealing ultimately with five
learnable models in the terms of how do I do
sensing, how do I do the estimation of the state, what is
the disease progression model, what is the therapy planning, and how the therapy is
delivered. So now let's take it one by one. Right?
So the first topic is that how do we do sensing?
As I said, right here we provide a lot of imaging,
laboratory information. And
actually, I want to show you one example on how we improve sensing.
And that example is coming from MR, where two years and a
half ago we introduced DeepResolve.
DeepResolve is about
a technology that makes MR much faster
by reconstructing from the k-space into the image
with the help of AI. Yeah? So now, an
MR is not 10 or 20%, but can be, you see,
73% faster. So we have many organizations
that are improving their flow in MR by increasing the
capability with DeepResolve to scan more patients
more efficiently. And you see in the world up to now, in two
and a half years, we have more than 44 million scans done with this
technology with AI-based reconstruction.
Now, the next step is how do you interpret
images? And here the next generation comes,
is not only looking at specific, say, radiological
findings, but looking into how do we generate a full
report. And there are new technologies emerging, large
databases in which the
AI technology is capable to generate full report
and also us being able to integrate it in the
radiologist workflow.The next topic in the
space of radiation oncology is
once the decision is made about radiation therapy,
is how do you
generate a plan? And the first topic is
to do the simulation, and then
very important here is to have the
auto-contouring. Auto-contouring means that you need to
focus on the organs at risk, you need to focus on the lesion, and you see
here this is a regulatory approved system that we have.
It covers more than 200 organs at risk, plus clinical target
volumes,
and includes lymph nodes,
stations in pelvic, head and neck, and breast cancer. Yeah.
And we have recently released also the contouring for
brain metastasis
from MR,
together with multiple other organs at risk
that correspond to the brain. And this
is also fascinating because such technology would
allow a better and better treatment of metastasis.
And the next step is radiation therapy planning.
Now, radiation therapy planning is
today,
if we look at the head and neck scenario,
you see it's a quite involved process
coming after the simulation and going into creating the
prescription, initializing the plan
optimization, and then going to physicians review,
the refinement, and then final evaluation.
So this actually can take quite a bit of time.
So the question is that where AI can
change everything. So now we have technology in the
development where actually the entire
optimization, starting from the simulation to the deliverable
plan, goes in under a second on a standard
hardware. So this is a really fascinating evolvement,
some order of magnitude faster of what's happening.
So if you really think today what would be the
potential evolution of radiation therapy planning is that the
interactive plan optimization powered by AI end to
end or what we call AI RT, in which you press the
button and you see the plan, and if you want to do any iteration, you do an
iteration, and that would be a joint session of physician and planner.
And after that, of course, there are many, many other topics where AI is
relevant,
relating into how do you deliver therapy, such as the motion
estimation, multiple elements here,
looking at the brachy, looking at the external beam, interventional
oncology. And once the therapy is being delivered, the
question is how do you
handle the outcome management? And ultimately,
it's an entire loop that goes again and again,
looking into, again, sensing how the therapy has made
and what needs to be done, what is the patient's data again and again.
So therefore, I believe it's very important to understand that
this loop is not one shot, but it's happening again
and again. The patient state is constantly changing.
And for that, also our
digital oncology system, Oria Core, we
try to have everything that
helps the information integration.
But again, we try to introduce a lot of efficiencies in
processing this entire information.
As you can see in my very short
lecture here,
I address a substantial complexity
of the topic that is happening only in radiation
oncology. But now another element is that how do we make
everything more efficient? And for that, let me talk
just a couple of words about the operational twin for department of
hospitals. So now, this relates to the
capability of agents to achieve
user-specified KPIs, key performance indicators,
under dynamic conditions.
What I mean dynamic conditions for a department can be is that
patient delays, workforce unavailability,
machine down, cybersecurity, whatever you can imagine
that can change the typical workflow.
So now, the new technology, again, think everything in terms of
having the capability of a supercomputer to train.
So the new technology is that you're capturing the data from
the department.
Based on that data, you do exascale simulations, billions
of simulations. And
with that data,
use that data to train the agents
that learn how to deal with various
exceptions, with various variabilities,
with various dynamic conditions while focusing to deliver
the quality and the time. So we have now
agents that are having the runtime
and also making strategic
changes on how everything should run.
So now,
one specific topic is that we integrate
such technology, advanced scheduling technology into
Oria. So where AI evaluates patient needs, machine
availability, and scheduling constraints, and then generate
optimized appointment and recommendations in one click.
So you can see here the AI scheduling process.
You have the patient demand, machine capacity, operational
constraints, clinical priority, machine availability, and
computer scheduling rules, and then pretty much the AI is
delivering recommendations, and
you have quite a number of benefits.But now think about
that.
Again, having such scheduling, and this is only one example,
involves quite a bit of complexity coming from the
environment. Each environment is very different.
So now when we think of in terms of the autonomous agents,
is the capability to
capture the environment complexity with the
overall large-scale optimization framework.
And this is where the autonomous agents are coming into place, and
the story is, again, providing the proper
synergy between gen AI, the capability of
understanding very high complexity with the capability
of high-end simulations and high-end
optimization.
So now think about where things are going in the
future.
We see the
roadmap into
scaling the operational twin,
not only at the department but
for the entire health system. So now you see
at the base, you see the topic of staff and patient and
machine scheduling for
various departments. But then when you go to the high level,
you're talking about
service coordination and balancing.
Meaning, what is the journey of this patient, and how do I make sure that the
journey of each and every patient is optimized across
various departments? Going even higher level is about
capacity management, and ultimately,
multiple CEOs are interested in what are my
operational strategies. Can I model at a larger scale my operation
strategies?
So now let's go back and draw some conclusions from
here. So from a technology standpoint, there are three
very important elements. You have the gen AI that has a very
important promise, and already there are so many examples out there
in which the knowledge of the world comes back to our
fingertips.
So that's a very important thing.
But certainly there are two more elements here.
One is large-scale optimization.
How do I develop agents that are benefiting from the
knowledge from the world, but also they are optimizing in a
dynamic fashion certain tasks, like scheduling,
patient journey, and so forth. And then the other part, which
is equally important, what is the role of simulations?
So I had there the disease evolution model.
And today a lot of disease evolution model is mostly part of the
guidelines. But still now, think about
how do I model the tumor complexity?
How do I model the tumor environment? And so on and so forth.
So we have quite a bit of simulations out there.
Now, those simulations were not scalable up to now, and the
synergy between the large-scale simulations and
everything that's coming from gen AI, this will be yet another paradigm
that is evolving. So think about these three
triangle that would drive us forward.
This triangle that would drive us forward.
Number one is everything that's happening in gen AI.
Number two, large-scale simulations, and number three is
that large-scale optimizations.
And with that, thank you so much for listening. Thank you.
Thank you so much for the illuminating presentation,
Dr. Doran. I'll open it now to the floor
for questions. We do have time for a few
questions. There are mics in the room.
Don't be shy.
Hi, Saren Rothberg, stage four cancer survivor,
33 years. And I'm just curious,
are you using patients and patient
advocates to develop these systems?
I'm a AI. I wrote the first AI study in
cancer survivorship in 2019. Just curious.
Yes. The
short answer is yes. Especially
related to activities in radiation oncology.
We have quite a number of
contacts and advising, and actually you see
among our colleagues, we have patient
advocates. I would say that it's
very important because let me try to reiterate.
That's the reason we're here, to make a difference for the patient.
It's also true that
we're trying to
bring more, as I said, efficiency,
effectiveness, but also the capability
to address more patients to cancer.
All statistics are showing that cancer will only grow.
So having patients very close is very important.
Yeah.
It was really impressive and very clear. Thank you.
Thank you.
Good morning. Steve Schneibel, Cancer Research Catalyst.
Thank you for the excellent talk. Very interesting.
Obviously, there was a lot of work being done with AI.
That's something of an understatement.
And as these tools are emerging and ultimately being adapted
between healthcare systems, there is going to be a certain amount of
competition. So,
while recognizing that you are here on behalf of Siemens, I'm just curious what
your perspective might be for how healthcare systems can think about which
tools being developed right now are best,
and how different tools can talk to each other, and to make
sure that as
different AI modalities emerge for healthcare, they're not
being siloed off from each other. Thank you.
Yeah. Thank you for the question. So no, I can give you a bit
of a perspective. I'm in this field for more than 20
years, 25 years, something like that.
So there is a
clear evolution.
And I'm coming from a generation that was doing machine
learning 25 years ago, and when we tried to do it in healthcare, people
were asking question, "Why the heck are we spending time with that?"
So that's my humble beginning in this field.
But now it's the opposite. We see a lot of
promise in AI. And it's always useful to
see
the evolution from tools to
systems.
I like to use the word systems
because everything that's happening today in AI is beyond
a tool.
And
if you read,
I just finished reading this, "A Giant Leap"
where the author is
speaking about the future of AI systems, where
actually we have to treat such systems as really
powerful systems that would provide scientific
advice, that would provide guidance, and so on and so forth.
And we should start thinking of having such systems
evaluated with the same rigorousness that we evaluate
today clinicians. Meaning that to have
a clear curriculum to test these
systems, to test everything, to reassess
their performance, and so on and so forth.
So again, it's a very, very, very interesting
evolution. And again, coming back to this triangle, the
capability of gen AI to help us handling
complexity, plus the capability of us doing
a lot of very powerful simulations.
So that means that you can scale simulations, and you can scale
also the optimization of the systems.
To me, the future is fascinating. But to me, again, for a
patient, it's very simple. What is the contribution for me?
What is the contribution for me? What exactly do we need
to do as a community to make the patient's
life better?
Thank you very much. I have another question.
We have another few minutes. Your group worked on
AI RT, and that impressive software generates a
plan in under a second,
let's say, for prostate.
I was wondering, this compresses, importantly,
the
turnaround time. It could also compress
the experience for the physician, right?
And so in the context of AI in the loop, I feel
there is a good question there to be asked.
How do we make sure that these new systems,
this agentic workflow speed up without eroding
useful, meaningful human supervision?
And what does meaningful look in practice to you?
Yeah. So thank you for the question.
I would see
this topic
a bit
from the other side, in the sense that the capabilities
of evolving AI to get answers, to get
solutions much faster than before, it
would
eliminate, I would say, what we call a friction
that we see today in everything in the IT
systems of
taking time to get answers,
taking time to get optimization, taking time to
not do everything in real time. Because at the moment where
everything is run in real time, that you can imagine a lot
of workflows being changed and being much, much more
efficient than today. Today, that's the story, right?
If the system doesn't give me an answer immediately, then due
to the time pressure, I need to switch my work to a different
problem and come back today, tomorrow, and so on and so forth.
So this is very, very, very interesting paradigm,
eliminating friction from delays in the answer of the
system. Yeah.
Thank you very much.
There's one more question.
Just quickly. So thank you for the talk.
It's incredibly fascinating. I
would look at this and think then, how do I
apply this to an academic hospital?
Have you done test cases or taken these systems and applied them in hospitals?
And I have a second part of the question which is,
AI is really rapidly evolving. You're watching it change daily.
And rapid evolution and clinical systems are not normally words that come together
in the same sentence.
How do you see the rapid evolution to be incorporated into
clinical processes that are normally very controlled and very slow to change?
Yeah.
Thank you for the question. So almost everything that you have seen here,
we run with hospitals. We run with academic hospitals,
and very much depends on the nature of the
problem. We run the high end with academic, but
also we work quite a bit with underserved
hospitals or
hospitals serving
various
underserved communities. So it's a range of
problem. And to me,
the second topic is equally relevant in the
current environment. I guess that we all
experience, number one, is that we are overloaded by
documentsCreated by gen AI,
by messages and so on, so forth. But also you see a lot of
software nowadays,
and while there is so much software out there, still the
pipeline to get topics regulatory approved is
still very slow. So we hope that a lot of
transformation will happen in the translation
aspect.
While of course, keeping the focus on the safety and
effectiveness for the patient.
Excellent. Thank you again, Dr. Komoniyi.
Our next speaker is Dr. Taehyong Hwang,
Founding Director from the Center of Molecular
Artificial Intelligence at Vanderbilt University Medical Center.
The first center of its kind in a clinical setting, dedicated to
leveraging molecular AI to directly improve patient care.
He also serves as Director of AI Research in Surgical
Sciences, and now a chair and professor at VUMC.
His work integrates AI with molecular biology and
advances cancer research, transplant science, precision
medicine, developing technology such as spatial 3D and
4D molecular profiling to uncover molecular mechanisms,
identify novel biomarkers, and designing
target therapeutics. Bringing the perspective of a
research lab with such a deep
knowledge is actually how we can turn the molecular AI into
translatable tools. I really look forward to what he'll teach
us today. Dr. Hwang, the floor is yours. Thank you.
Thank you. Thank you very much.
I have one question for everybody.
Have you ever wondered how a drug works
in human body?
You might know the mechanisms, but we never watched that.
So today, we'll watch together.
So this is the real tumor. This is HER2-positive cell.
What you are looking at is real tumor expressing HER2.
The NR2 is in a pink color. That's the drug
that are very successful at treating patient with HER2-positive
cell. Now, what we can see is that when it
administered the drug, after 24 hours,
whether those drug actually delivered to the tumor,
whether they bind to the target tumor cell, whether they
are really killing it,
and then whether they internalize how this payload release,
and then do you see the response?
That's something we never have seen before, but today,
that's what we're going to watch together. So this is not a prediction.
This is not a simulation. This is real
tumor, real drug that we treat today for patient.
So my name is Taehyong Hwang. I'm an induct director of the AI research at
Vanderbilt. Today, what I want to talk about is that it's not about
simulations, it's not about research, even it's not about development.
The platform that we use daily, the platform that
we want to use to treat our patient, our loved ones.
So the talk is about the 4D oncologists and then
how AI help us to understand and watch
the drug works.
So
we understand that the world that we live is in
3D.
Our cell is 3D. Our body is 3D.
When drug enter to human body, now it becomes 4D
because we have time domain. And then when drug
penetrate, we always need to calculate how much dose,
how long we need to give this drug, and then whether how long does it
last. So every single momentum
that matters, and then we need to think about 4D domain.
But when you treat patient,
when we use our drug,
as long as we give the drug to the patient, we
give the drug with the hope. With the hope that that
drug can reach out to the tumor, and then it's going to bind, and then
it's going to kill the tumor cell.
But again, those decisions should have been made within 4D dimension,
not the 2D. The today's standard of care, everything we
simplify. We cut the tumor, we make a slide as 2D.
We use the information to prescribe
treatment, even though the way we should treat our patient
is to 4D.
So one of the example what we're going to show that is that as part of
NCI-Cancer Moonshot Project, initiated by NCI
with my colleague Lingha Wang. So we are heavily
studying gastric cancer. So the consequences is simple.
If you don't use 4D, this is what we see.
Patients with gastric cancer, 800,000 deaths per
year.
The challenge is that once it's metastasized, their median
survival is less than 11 months, and then majority of
patient do not have targeted therapy.
Then how are we going to change this?
We trying to build the model, not just model, with the
platform. Cancer is very complex.
One single model with large parameters cannot solve
everybody's tumor problem or cancer problem.
So we want to use agentic AI, the agent with
AI, with intelligence, bring them together,
orchestrate them, and then integrate all this information together,
make one most important decisionWhich
drug, A drug, will work for my patient?
So the first agent is developed with LG AI
Research.
The second one is how to watch it. The third agent
is we want to see their behavior with tumor.
And then the last one is integrators.
The first, the agent is, again, developed by LG
AI Research, is very critical.
What we're trying to do here is not about research, like I said.
It's not about development.
We want to implement it as of today.
We want to deliver it to the patient.
All this research and development, there is one thing we need to
do, which academic cannot do.
Regulatory implementation, make it as the product so that
our patient can use it. So not just for LG AI
Research's amazing model, but again, all these
logistics we want to build together.
So also what we are doing is that we are not building it in a
separate platform. We want to embed it in clinical setting, in
standard care. That's what we do. So we don't interrupt
any standard care mechanisms or asking any additional
material. But once we have those standard care material, which
is H&E as a diagnostic, that's how we start our journey.
So this is LG Axon AI model.
I don't think we have the
voice, but let me introduce that. So once we have
H&E from surgical paths or routine pathology lab,
then agentic AI co-developed by LG AI, we look at
all these NCCN guideline, ESMO guideline.
Because what we care about is that if there are standard care, we can
actually maximize our algorithm to provide better treatment.
That's something we want to know. And then once we have certain
markers, the markers even we don't have from the NCCN
guideline or ESMO guideline, our agentic AI don't
stop there. We want to look for the additional potential targets.
Potential target to use from off-label potential
target, we believe that AI can guide better treatment
response. We also do not just simply looking at that.
We also bring the large language model developed by LG AI Research.
We're looking at all these regulatory process.
We're looking at all potential clinical trial based on inclusion,
exclusion criteria, so that that guide us that what
we should prioritize even to staining, even though it's not
the NCCN guideline or ESMO guideline.
That give us the time that are most precious
for our patient.
So let's say that the agentic AI we develop with
LG AI provide a list of things we should do, including the
standard care. So for example, there is potentially HER2,
then we're going to do that IHC staining because that's the standard care.
But let's say that maybe there are FGFR2 which is emerging treatment
modality. Still in the clinical trial, there are potentially
a lot of the expression or expressing cancer cell we might
be useful to try. Then our agentic
AI can prioritize that. Even though this is not standard care,
please generate IHC staining for FGFR2b so that
if our drug doesn't work from standard care, maybe we can
rapidly enroll this patient to the clinical trial with FGFR2
inhibitors or ADC. So now
second one is that
before we give the drug, we have the
chance to look at that, which drug is
really going to be effective for our patients.
During the biopsy, we can do standard thing like IHC staining,
other thing, but again, we can actually use that, culture them to
make patient-derived organoid or cell line.
Now even before the standard care like HER2 ADC, we can
actually treat the drug with
our patient tumor, your tumor, and then we can watch it
whether ADC can really kill the tumor cell
from our patient body.
When you're looking at this, this is how ADC works.
When you give the drug, it bind to surface, and then ADC
internalize, and then lysosome comes in, and it's wrapping up, and
it cleaves linker. And then payload release and the
apoptosis happening. We can measure how much payload we need to
give. We can measure that. Which ADCs might be the better ADC
to provide to our patient. On the right side, what you are looking at is
the case that the ADC Trop2 didn't work.
The reason why Trop2 ADC didn't work is not because
of ADC for Trop2 is bad. It's
because it's patient tumor. Those patient tumor cell
doesn't express lysosome, which means that we cannot cleave this linker,
and then we cannot release payload.
So we can tell you that based on all this experiment, which we can do
less than 30 days, we can plan
all these multiple drug, existing drug, FDA approved or
investigate drug so that we can provide this
information with the matrices, with the quantification to
our oncologists.
The next one is that
how it's going to behave in the future.
All the standard care what we are looking at is that the first thing is
staging. Oh, this is early cancer stage one.
I'm sorry, this is stage four because it already metastasized.
But when you give the new adjuvant therapy or adjuvant treatment, do
you know that how this tumor going to behave even though you treat
the patient?
Using very special device with microfluidic device with
aligned extracellular matrix. Now using the tumor, we can
actually let see that how this tumor going to
behaveWhat you are seeing right now is the tumor from breast
cancer. And then what you are seeing is that it has a lot of
metastatic potential. What does that mean?
Even though we treat patient with the standard care, we should be very cautious.
We should very aggressively observe and monitor the patient tumor
development, because what we are seeing is that this patient,
this tumor, unfortunately, likely invade to
distant organs.
So that we can plan ahead. We don't wait to six months, and then we don't want
to say, "I'm sorry." We want to say that "We have
plan for you, and now we know how to behave, and
then we going to do best thing for your tumor to
prevent this is happening."
And then what we do is that we accumulate all this information,
millions of billions of zillions of information from all different
parameters and the picture of the videos and then
all this information. And then we're going to put them together.
That's our orchestra. We're going to use more than millions
of billions of the time point to build this model
from, again, actual patient tumor.
And then we're going to decide that should we give this drug, even though
we see how it works in their patient tumor or
organoid or cell lines, to really show that this will really
benefit the patient. So that's something we build as
called Terrain.
This is work with Lingha Wang from MD Anderson.
This is real tumor. This is stomach cancer.
We resect two regions, and then we generate data, which is spatial
multimodal data using singular genomics G4X
platform. In each side, this is the two different
regions, and because we believe there are two different tumor
microenvironment.
And we also generate the protein data so we can look at the vascular
structures. Why? When you simulate or predict how drug
works, drug actually give through IV, which means that it
circulates through the blood.
I mean, the vascular structures. So we need to understand the
structure, how we simulate that. And then also we need to look at
all the standard guideline. Based on
their profile of what kind of tumor cell, what's the composition?
Are there a lot of stromas? Are there a lot of exhausted T-cell?
Are there a lot of other things we should care about?
Now, within seven days, we can generate all these data
right before we prescribe or decide their treatment.
So now using all this information, again, the information we
already learn from the patient who didn't respond to
treatment. Using this information, we can accumulate a
lot of the decision process. What
you're looking at is that we can profile and prioritize
all existing 56 FDA approved ADC drug, and then
how it's going to work. And then now you can watch it,
how this drug going to penetrate and deliver and kill
the tumors. And then what's the potential toxicities?
What's the potential resistance mechanisms you're going to develop?
So once you can look at that, then again, all this
information comes to agent, the agent who
can actually interact with our oncologist and then our medical
experts. That's something we never done before
because cancer is biology. It's very complex.
There are millions of zillion information.
When you go to the real tumor board, we never talk about their tumor biology.
We just talk about their staging, there is mutations, and that's
it, even though we can collect a lot of information.
So what you're looking at is that this is the real time we simulated, and now you
can see that based on each cycle, when time goes by,
how much drug can penetrate and kill that based on the
data from real patient tumor, we about to provide the
treatment. We have a lot of options, and we can always
simulate that because, again, this is real-time decision.
Once you have all this information, what you are looking at is that
in this actually the figures and then different
drug, different sequential treatment.
Now we have some answers. Maybe it's not the perfect
answers, but again, it's better than guessing.
That's something we can provide. So once we have all this
information, what we're going to do that is that, like I said, we're going to
discuss that, the discussion with agent
AI. So all this information already went through.
So we did all this simulation in a backbone.
And when you meet with tumor board, this is something what we want to do.
We want to discuss what's the recommended based on NCCN guideline,
what's what we simulated, and then now with the real
patient and their oncologist going to
decide that which one would be the best treatment.
Now what you are seeing is our agent giving some of the opinion.
The human expert says that this particular treatment, two of
them agree. One says we want to be cautious.
Another one says that maybe we should give a go.
And then our agent also provide information, information with the molecular
data, with billions of zillions of parameters.
And then human decide that, because at the end of day,
it's the decision we make with our patient and with
the oncologist.
So you already saw that what we did.
And then like I said, we don't want to just say that our agent
or AI can do everything because it's
not true.
But one thing I can tell you that is that we can try our best
to simulate and predict and observeSo
that when you have a lot of answers, or when you don't have any
answers, that is something we can help with you.
So next two slide, I'm going to show you that in the real case scenario.
This is a patient with HER2 palliative, and then there are also ineligibility
because this patient can get the immunotherapy.
Now you wonder that, should I give to HER2 ADC or should I give it to
anti-PD-1 immunotherapy? Usually, we give the anti-PD-1
first. But based on our agent AI with real data we
generate, we found that there are a lot of stroma, which means that drug might not
penetrate. Drug never reach the tumor. Then what are we going to do?
That's what we are doing.
From the patient tumor, we drive their cell line.
We simulate that. Simulate means it's not simulation like the virtual.
Use their cell line co-culture with their fibroblasts, and then we treat
them real time. And then we can see that how this
tumor behave or it respond to this drug that we are about
to prescribe. If it works, that's the hope.
That's better than the guessing. And that's something we want to utilize.
What we are looking at is that patient with HER2 positive, HER2 negative, that's
what we're mimicking. And we can show you the ADC with by standard
impact. We can actually still have some of the benefit of the clinical decision.
After that, again, what we do?
We discuss with AI all this information with real
human expert. And then we're going to say that
actually, even though immunotherapy with good drug, maybe ADC can
open the door for stroma barriers.
And then anti-PD-L1 would be the better choice.
That is something we can use AI we've never done
before, using real experiment. Another case is
much harder cases. This patient doesn't have any markers.
HER2 negative. There is the lack of the immune cell expressing
PD-1, PD-L1. There is no colon 8.2.
There is no biomarker. Still, we can use her
tumor to try to see that whether some
of the drug might work. So that's what we are doing on the left
side than right side, that we're showing the Trop2 ADC is very
effective at killing her tumor cell.
After this, we can also do surgical resections, and then
based on behavior with tumor we saw from the scalp,
from the data we see, we can prepare what's the next.
What if this treatment doesn't work?
That's the biggest fear of the patient.
Then we can say that we already have plan.
We already try all these drugs, so we know what's the next.
So that's something we want to give to our patient, the hope.
So this is what we showed today, and then I just want to
close this. Until now,
like I said, we gave the drug to the patient with
the hope. The hope that this drug reach to your
tumor. The drug will kill your tumor cell.
And then we wait.
Many of cases, it didn't work like what we hoped.
But as of today,
we can watch it together with our patient, and then we can decide together
with our patient, our doctors, and our agent.
So thank you very much.
Outstanding presentation. Thank you so much.
Please come to the mics for questions.
Hi. Marcus Munari, B Pharma.
The question I have is probably twofold.
One is you started out with saying we
don't consider the time dimension so far in treatment, but we do PK sampling,
we do biomarker.
So the first question is that component.
Mm-hmm.
So how do you see the big difference there?
And the second one is
how does it scale?
Mm-hmm.
What are the statistics behind it?
So have you compared this system versus whatever's
used now state-of-the-art?
Mm-hmm.
Do they fall apart?
So good question. Actually, it comes to just one question.
So there are drug screenings. You can measure the efficacy,
toxicity, and PK study. Like animal model, cell line.
What's the difference? The difference is that if you're just thinking of ADC as
biologics, how ADC works, it bind,
first of all. It should bind on target, off target, right? We need to measure that.
And then we need to look at internalization.
Internalization does not equal to drug works because we need to look at whether
linker is cleavage. Because linker cleavage doesn't mean that it's going to work
because what's the payload? So the
payload release doesn't mean that it's going to work, because if it leakish, it's
going to actually make a lot of toxicity.
So all this information I just talked to you, how we actually
get the result. You get the one plate paper saying that this
is cell viability with one hour, two hour,
24 hour. What I can tell you that is that ADC, all this
internalization, lysosome, it doesn't work like what we expected.
When internalized, sometimes lysosome doesn't come in, which means that even though
drug internalize, even the drug works,
because of those tumor, it doesn't really actually express lysosome.
You cannot cleavage the linker. Which means that it's not because
this drug fail because your drug is not efficient.
It's because just how this tumor behavior.
So this is something we're trying to provide.
Not just replacing what you do, PK study, but we want to
show them that this is the information you can add.
And then the most important question, when you give the drug through
the mouse model or human,
how do you know how much drug actually delivered? You never know.
You cannot guess. Even you cannot get the information.
But based on what we are showing here, we can see it.
We can count it, how many drug, how many doses, how much of
them, and in real time. So I didn't show that real time
intro... focal meeting, but that's something I hope to show next
year. But that's something we can actually provide.
So I think there are a lot of discussion we can have, but we can have it after
maybe this presentation.
On the statistics bits, so did you-
So statistics, same. So all this data we have, like
AI, all this, we have locations we can show that based
on 2D level and the static level, on the real-time level.
So how many cell, how many drug, how many mouse we need to do?
I can tell you that whatever you do, we can do equally, and then we can add more
dimension, and we can also add more the
statistics.
But we can discuss that later.
Thank you for the excellent presentation.
I was just wondering, given the promise that this
has to be used in the clinic,
right now seemingly, off the shelf, it looks like the software is
ready. Are you considering any kind of measurement of
this platform's outcomes
for clinicians who may use it and
clinicians who are not using it, something like that to
measure the difference that it might make?
That's great question. So,
I just want to make clear, it's not something we use right now to
treat patients. So this is something we are developing together with
our
collaborators and industry partners like LG.
So to do that, of course, we need to go through all this regulatory process.
Maybe we need to do some clinical trial or some other thing.
So yes, because again, patient safety is the best thing.
So and that's something we differentiate with others.
We don't interrupt standard care.
We don't say it or claim it, you need to change the standard
care. So like I said, even patients that standard care, we can
prepare all the experiment and result, and then we know
the measure of patient don't respond to treatment. Then what's the next?
When you don't have any NCCN guideline.
When you don't have any ESMO guideline, patient who fail first line,
second line, third line. Because then the last step is that either you
get the chemo, which you don't know about what we're going to get, or you go to
actually, unfortunately, hospice setting.
But what if there is some drug we can give you the answer, the answer based on your
tumor? That's something we're trying to do.
So that's the opportunity. Still we can give the hope for the
patient who didn't really respond to standard care.
Excellent. Thank you very much. There is another question. Go ahead.
First thing is your slides are incredible. Did you make them?
Yes, I made them.
You use AI or you just design?
Slide scale, yes. Cloud design.
Did you?
But every single data and then the video is our real
experiment. There is no AI.
Okay. That was-
Just a style. But I guide that.
Yeah. It's so fun. Okay, that was number one.
Number two is, does the patient get to see-
Yes
... this creativity of, and how the
science is changing using AI, or is this just behind the
curtain for the medical team?
No. Everything involved with patient. That's why we make the visualization.
Visualization that even non-human expert can
understand. The reason is that this is real case scenario.
So right now, patient use AI. So when patient come with the news of
the cancer, they have pile of papers, and then they tell
their doctors, "I need to get this A drug, and then B drug, and C drug."
And the medical oncologist says that, "Oh, this is not guideline." "I don't care
about guideline, I'm going to pay for it.
Give me this drug and this drug because I read that."
Because as you know, in clinic, it doesn't work like that way, right?
Then sometimes we need to explain why, as the experts, as you're a
doctor, why this wouldn't be best option.
Mm-hmm.
We can show is that, for example, you want to get the immunotherapy, and the doctor
says that you are not eligible. You don't understand why.
We can take your tumor from biopsy during standard care, right?
And then we can show, quantify that how healthy your immune
cell are. Maybe on post-treatment, your immune cell are not healthy
anymore. Then there is also answer that we can actually boost the immune cell
later, right? That's something we can also consider.
But this process, showing your real tumor, and
then you wonder that after treatment, they said that, "Oh, thank you
very much. You finish your treatment.
Please come back six months later."
Then what we're going to think about?
Every day, every morning,
every time you're going to think about,
"Am I getting the best treatment or this is really working?"
That's the question, the fear we have.
We want to eliminate it.
When you come here, I will tell you, "Where is the drug?" I will
show is that they are working really hard for you.
That's the information we want to provide.
If it doesn't work, we also want to inform you and our physician so that
we can intervene earlier than later when it's too late.
So are you licensing this out to other hospitals, or is it
proprietary just to Vanderbilt?
No. So we're going to make the commercial product.
That's something we want to do because, again, without commercialization, we
cannot use it in clinical setting, which means that we cannot use for patient.
That's the path. So we designed this, again, it's not because of research.
It's because I want to use it. Because I have my family members
touched by cancer.
When cancer becomes personal, you cannot wait.
You need to do it. And this is something I do, and I
want to use it for my family member, too.
So thank you for being here. I really appreciate your time.
Excellent. Thank you very much.
Thank you.
Fantastic presentations. Thank you so much.
I thought, with such a deep and
wide set of presentations, how could I contribute
a little bit to this
conversation? And so here I wanted to bring to you
the perspective of the academic medical center.
AI that works across research, clinical care,
and education.
So,
before I start, I wanted to thank everybody at St.
Jude who has made this possible. All our
leaders, our patients, their families, the Office of
Data Science, Dr. Madan Babu, who architected most of what you'll see,
and our partners in IES, the CEO, the grad school, and
legal. What I want to show you today is a
story of acceleration. Why? Because
St. Jude's mission is to advance cures and means of prevention
for pediatric catastrophic diseases through research and treatment.
If you can ask one question to the next one who talks to you about AI
and clinical AI, let it be this one.
Ask them to measure time to patient.
There is a deafening level of
hype around AI. Ask them the point question.
Time to patient. I'm going to show you now a few
examples throughout what we do at St.
Jude along these five dimensions and how we
are getting better at time to patient, how we are
reaching more patients, and what are the AI systems that,
for instance, we are
exploring and with whom.
The very first thing that you'll realize you need when you want to traverse
that path is you need some sort of compass.
You need
something that sets the North Star.
And that, for us, is really the product that was put through the
vision for the data science initiative created by our CEO and
our scientific director. They wanted for St.
Jude to become a global leader in applying data sciences to
biological discovery. What does it mean to do that?
Well, after much consultation and
introspection and looking at what everybody else was doing and
where the industry and the academia was going, they
realized that for St. Jude to deliver on that mission, they had to create
a seamless ecosystem where experimental scientists,
clinical scientists, data scientists would work together
toward generating new knowledge that advances our understanding of
healthy and disease states for preventing and curing
pediatric catastrophic
diseases. That is why they put together the
Office of Data Science. The Office of Data Science
has in scope, really, three types of
topics. Pan-institutional initiatives.
Think about
data governance across the organization, enterprise-wide.
How do you tackle that? I promise you need an office for that.
Departmental level initiatives.
What is one exploration within one department?
How can we supercharge it, bringing data scientists there?
And then forward-looking initiatives. Quantum computing.
We know it's part of the research reality 20 years from
today, but is it also 10? Five? What about two?
What should we do today to bring closer that future to
us, and that means to our patients?
Center for Protein Design, Frontier Intelligence Labs, and edge
computing. For that, St. Jude has allocated about $200 million over the
next five years. We're going to hire 115
new positions, and that includes also funding for enhanced
infrastructure. So I'll start from the grad school and give you some
examples there and walk our way through global impact.
What are we doing in the grad school?
One of the very first things I'm excited to try next year with the next
cohort is the concept
that Cogniti brings, which is an AI clone of
the teacher. That is an AI created by the teacher, created
by the scientist, who can then be available to the
researcher, to the students 24/7.
The second one is a Socratic bot,
something that doesn't give you the answer but teaches you to
ask better questions.
The second one that I'll show very briefly is some
work that we're doing in foundational research, and for that, I
wanted to share that we gave our workforce access
through Cloud Research, Cloud Code, BioMCP, BioOmni, Cadence, you name
it. If you've seen something flashy at AACR or
beyond, I promise you, we are piloting it within the
right guardrails with data that is meaningful and
de-identified
and all of that. What does that mean?
It means that, for instance, to compile a report about
answering the question, "Catch me up on cell-free DNA landscape
across academia and industry," it takes now 20 minutes.
It used to take two weeks just for such a scoping
review. And now in 20 minutes, we got something like that, that it's tailored to
me, Renato, because it knows my background, knows my CV and all
of that. Another example I wanted to bring from this
aspect is what we're building with Google and DeepMind.
We introduced Co-Scientist at Kids just in October
of last year, and what we observed is
fascinating. Our research teams went from, "How
do I make sense of this data?" That they had been looking into for about
two years,
all the way to, we have now the CRISPR screening to validate the mechanic C
hypothesis. Used to take two years.Thanks to
Coscientist and the close collaboration with
Google, we looked at that in months.
We are now validating in the lab new hypotheses that
were generated thanks to these extremely powerful AI, which is
really a systems of AI plus ELO ranking, and please read the paper.
It's fascinating. It is something that we are currently
exploring. What you'll realize pretty quickly after you
start implementing some of these very powerful systems is that you need to
train your entire workforce, and that doesn't scale.
This AI is extremely powerful. Just explaining Coscientist to a
single scientist, it is a lot of work.
And so for that, we're building a community of practice.
That is something that spans the entire organization, from students to
researchers, department chairs, global,
everybody.
That is something that, for instance, we are seeing
materialize now in 160 people that show up to our
community of practice events that has multiple
special interest groups. I'll mention very briefly that the
one called AI Coding Agents has already 90
internal participants. And these people are hosting meetings.
What is your frustration? How do you this? How do you install that?
It is incredibly powerful to harness that internal community.
We're also organizing biohackathons for them.
160 participants showed up last year, 23 internal
departments, 55 total organization
working on 22 projects that were identified by St. Jude.
The next thing you realize is that you cannot just build these bottom
up. You need also to inform all the scientific and data
leaders. And for that, the Office of Data Science is working with every single
department chair and data leader in the organization.
We are bringing them together, whether they are from basic science or clinical
sciences, all the way through.
Just in February, we hosted the Data
Intensive Projects Retreat, the first of a series,
and we have 79 participants across EVPs, SVPs, department chairs,
data delegates from 22 departments.
We are creating this
community. The next thing you realize, and I'm so glad that
it was shown in the previous
presenter's slides, is that you cannot do this alone.
Especially after ChatGPT, it is evident that you need access to a
level of compute, a level of data that sometimes you don't have
access to internally. But which companies and
where is this expertise? Well, if you look at
the training compute that is required for specific
advancements, and I'll point here at AlphaFold 2, because
this was the 2024 Nobel Prize winner.
Very few hospitals will have access to this
computing power, and this is log scale.
That means that you're going to need thousands of years to reach, let's
say, the computing power that was used to train a GPT-5 level
model. So how do we tap that?
Partnerships. Networks on networks.
ML Commons is an international nonprofit that has
the mission of benchmarking AI and ML across
industry, and that allows us to access the
organizations that you see and the hyperscalers that you see on the screen.
The second one that we're tapping is called the Trillion Parameter Consortium.
Over there, we have multiple universities, multiple national labs
in the US, amazing industry partners.
And if you look at
the research institutes now, I'm so proud that we have also St. Jude.
What does it mean for our researchers?
It means when you look at the top 500, which is the list where
you have all the most powerful computers on Earth,
nine out of the top 10 computers
participate in TPC. And from my perspective, when we have to
train over 115 data scientists, even
having access to this network as a
workforce development opportunity, it's
really a game changer. Next one, I want to show you some
examples from what we're doing in clinical.
What we're bringing there is, of course, through a clinical AI and analytics
council. We're looking at specific use cases, evaluating
one by one and asking the tough questions.
Are we really improving patient outcomes? Are we improving their experience?
Are we improving the provider experience?
Are we making improvements also in healthcare access?
Are we optimizing costs and all that?
The other thing I'm excited about and that we'll start doing next is
doing something similar to what the FDA does.
They bucket an intervention into a risk
category, and that means we will be able to
organize certain AI types, clinical
AI, into given boxes for which we know the risk,
for which we don't know the benefit, and we want to evaluate it and assess it.
But at least bucketing the risk, this is important because this allows us
to bring more innovation faster to our patients.
Lastly, I want to mention what we're doing with Global.
We heard about the guidelines and how they are
transformative.
Over there, I'll share that we are building the
AREA Guide, which is an adaptive
guideline
for all the 450-member organization that
St. Jude Global
works with. And in that context, we're looking into
developing an AI agent that would gather the
evidence, present that evidence to the clinical committees, and then
tailor that down, tailor that up, depending on
what's available in that specific hospital.
SoIf you look at the partners that are working with us, this is
450 of them across the globe. Here now we are
measuring not just time to patient, but it's time to patient
in Kenya, time to patient in South America, in that hospital.
And so this is really the story that
I wanted to convey to you and a summary of
how we are really measuring time to patient.
And if I can leave you with one message, let it be this.
Next time you see an AI presentation, ask
the
question, time to patient. That means, how long did it take from, "Hey, I published
this molecule in 'Nature'" to, "Hey, I injected the first child."
Right? "I've run the first clinical trial, and I've run the
first clinical trial in a phase III, and I've
reached a underserved population."
With that, thank you, everybody, and I'll be happy to take any
questions.
Hi. I'm Anne Marie. I used to work at Dana-Farber with Nancy
Lynn, Melissa, and Greg.
So I was just curious, so how do you decide which initiatives should
involve your team in AI at St. Jude and maybe
even previous work too?
So that's an excellent question, and it's a prioritization one, right?
We have only a limited number of experts, although we are
training our workforce. But AI expertise is still
niche. So we're doing two things. One, we are training the entire
workforce, at least on the AI basics, right?
And next, we'll look at the data basics and even
answering the question inside any organization, who do I work
with to explore question X? I promise it's going to be a fishing
expedition in any academic medical center.
So we're working towards building better navigation from that, and that's why the
Office of Data Science is important. The second one, what to pick?
This is really what we try to answer with
these five questions that are ranked in this order. Right?
If you are able to show patient outcome improvement, your
project will be prioritized. Similarly, if you are able to show
that you're actually improving healthcare access, it will be
prioritized. Let's say you have a new molecule, something that it's easier to
export, doesn't need refrigeration and all of that.
So this is a ranked order
that we are developing. But what we have front of mind is
always impact to our patient. That is the number one question that we ask.
Thank you.
Sure.
So I also have question. So this is amazing.
So one of the key challenges as institutional
decision maker, right? So every single model
upgrade, sometimes within weeks, within a
day, right? And then as they're implementing this
version, sometimes we are not allowed to use the
better version, even if you know that it is much, much better,
like 10 times.
Yeah.
So how St. Jude's actually place the
policy? Again,
potential uncertainties were like...
I don't know how I can actually describe.
But as big organization, as the
first, one of the largest institution in implementing all this
data science, how are you guys going to actually plan and deal with
that?
That's an excellent question. We build, we test, we validate on
GPT 5.4. Tuesday, 5.5 is released,
right? How do we adapt for that? That's a fantastic question.
We are very fortunate to work also with regulatory
colleagues. They pointed us to what the FDA does, specifically
for AI as a medical device, and they suggest
using PCCP, which is basically a
plan where you tell the FDA what you're going to
take as a reference cohort, what you are going to take
as a benchmark, and then they ask you to write down a plan
of what is acceptable within what parameters.
Now, if GPT 5.5 or 5.7,
you run the benchmark, you analyze it against the data, and you are
within parameters, you're in the clear.
You don't have to go back to the FDA because you have not changed the risk
profile. You might have improved, actually,
on the efficacy profile. And so this is the stance that we're
trying to take internally, and that's why, for instance, that
risk grouping that I showed in the clinical area
makes a lot of sense because it allows us speed without
really slowing down
the progress. It allows us to catch the new risk.
Maybe one comment from me. So great
observation on the PCCP. Actually, we have quite a number of products
now approved under the PCCP, and that allows
us to evolve the products to the next
feature or to
the next capability. But again, according to the
constraints provided by the plan.
Yep.
So
this is what we have in mind, but if anyone has better plans, come
tell us. The FDA, we were at the meeting with them.
They're also exploring new ways because they know how fast AI is
developing. Go ahead.
So I just did an article with Forbes, and
I was pro-AI in healthcare for
women, and the
article was negative. Like very suspicious,
very negative, very antiquated. And so I was trying
to figure out how do we get
people off that mentality? And I was
wondering ifMaybe we put together
a
patient bill of rights of sorts.
So because you are on the
other side, supposedly, what would you suggest goes
in that? Because it shouldn't be limited what you're doing,
but maybe if I can present that, we're looking at the
protections of the patient, what would each of you suggest
should be in that, that wouldn't be so constrictive, but
I can offer?
That's an excellent question. Thank you so much, and thank you for the very
important role that you bring. In general, one
thing that I mention to everybody developing
clinical AI is, if you don't have the patient at the table,
or if you ask the patient what they think about the product when you're talking to
the FDA, you're at least two years too late.
So that is of key importance. The question that you ask is really something
that we look at answering towards education.
Education, because there is a lot of fear about AI.
There was a lot of fear about computers.
There were probably a lot of fears about cars when we were using
horses, right? And education, having a license,
having a risk that everybody can understand and can
relate to is the key that allowed us these big
leaps. And so that's why, for instance, we teach it in the
grad school throughout. That's something that the new
students will have at their availability, and they
have to learn how to properly use so that those
antiquated articles maybe are not written in the future.
How can we stop it today? I would say maybe your
organization can write a comment piece on
that article. Patient voices are, as
my colleague stated, they are the reason why we are here
and why we're not in another organization or we're not in
another line of business. So
from my perspective, I would say the patient voice
should be heard, especially by those who claim that
they're speaking on behalf of the patient and sometimes they're just projecting
their own opinion or fear.
It was definitely-- It was as bold as,
AI is meant to trick
and own your
material, and you're not getting any bene-- I
said, "Take me out of the article unless you write my
perspective."
Yeah.
And so they wrote my perspective. But I'm really trying to figure out,
what can I show a journalist
or somebody that's really negative, say, "But here's what
they're agreeing not to do."
Mm-hmm.
They're not selling our data. They're using
security precautions. They're not putting in our things into
open systems. This is closed system.
I'm just trying to get something to offer-
Yeah
... so that they quiet down and just really get excited about
what we're all trying to do here using artificial intelligence.
Yeah.
If I were to guess what happened is that the journalist
that wrote the piece wanted attention, wanted the
piece to be sensationalistic, and wanted to
contrast certain opinions, and they exaggerated
the views that were presented. I think
when you have clearly stated, as you said, that this is the risk
box, right? That we're giving this new tool,
right? Is not something that people want to argue
with because they're already thinking about the benefit.
So I would say education is something that you should
always point and you could point to these people, especially in the context
of fears.
As it's recognized by everybody, we are not
risk-free at all, all the time, right?
What we have in our hospitals
is not a risk-free business at all, right?
Chemotherapy is a sort of poison, right?
And so are all the interventions. So this idea
that the risk has to be zero, even when you talk to a single
doctor, it is not zero, right? Because as my colleagues
also anticipated, you are going to have multiple
opinions, right? And as a patient, you'll wrestle with the question, am I getting
the right one? Am I getting the wrong one, right?
And that is something that we are still figuring out as a
society. But if I can give you one, it would be really education for the
masses. I feel AI should be taught even in elementary
school. We're teaching computers already.
It's not that big of a delta to say, "Hey, this is
generative AI. This is non-generative AI.
This is the math that goes in." The math is already
taught. It's just that we have to wrestle a little bit as a society with this
new big experiment.
Do you have a patient education program on AI?
We do, and that is something that we are developing closely with
the colleagues at SCEO. We have this
program called Together, which is geared towards the
patient. How do we use AI to
bridge that gap? It's an open question, but I promise you that the
patients will be at the table. Because, again, we're doing it for them, with them,
not to them.
Thank you.
Yeah. Hello. Thanks for the excellent talk. My name is Anna.
I'm working in data science as well.
So first of all, it's really amazing how you
bring data science to the clinics in practice.
And I was wondering
if you could tell us a bit more about your perspective, where AI
currently makes the biggest differences for the patients.So
is it diagnostic tools? Is it drug development?
Or is it rather right now more processing
information and make it accessible?
So maybe you could give your perspective on that, how it is now and how you
see it in five years, maybe.
Thank you. That's an excellent question.
I would say there is a review that we are compiling with 30-plus
colleagues to answer exactly that question.
If you leave me your email, I'll make sure to send you the PDF when it's out, or I
can show you the draft we have, but we are answering exactly that
question, right? At every step of the way, what is the impact that
we're making at that level? To me, there is also another component.
Right now, if you look at this picture, right?
It feels a little bit like we're retrofitting.
We are putting AI here, we're putting AI here, we're putting AI here, here,
and here. Right? In the hope that it accelerates every step.
The other part of the answer to me will be AI that will allow us to
go all the way through faster in a safer way.
I haven't seen it yet,
but this is the time compression. Is this still going to
take us $2 billion and 10 years, 15 years
to take a drug to the market? Or we can compress that
entire thing end to end. That's the other thing that I
look forward to seeing. I hope it answers your question.
Yeah, thanks. That's an interesting perspective, and also looking forward
to read that report. Yeah. Thanks.
What's your time to pi-- I'm just kidding.
You said to ask that. I really enjoyed seeing
the org chart and seeing that your entire institution is all
in on making sure that employees are upskilled.
Obviously, the big focus here is improving patient outcomes and
improving the speed of research.
But there's also a tremendous amount of opportunity for these same systems to be
integrated across large, necessarily
bureaucratic institutions like St. Jude.
You see thousands, if not many more, of
patients, and there's a lot of paperwork that goes along with that.
So,
as part of this initiative, is St. Jude looking to implement
AI on the administrative side as well?
Absolutely, 100%. One thing that I did not show is that
we have a mirror council in
admins and in operations. Exactly as we have
the clinical AI one for AI and analytics, we
have one
over there, and these are the colleagues that are leading that effort together
with others, let's say, in finance, in HR, right?
All the key administrative
components. I would say the other thing that could be
extremely interesting from what you asked is
bringing a platform that means
a common shared platform, let's say, across
our 450 partners' hospitals. If you ask me what would
be something really impactful, that would be part of
the solution. Bring a software platform, and not just that, because that is going
to be the easy part. Bring also the processes to
operate that platform and allow you as a researcher, as
a patient, as a clinician, to traverse this
faster, right? Okay, I published this molecule.
Who do I talk to to have the clinical trial?
How do I design that, right? I'm a biologist. I know my biology.
I don't know how to run a clinical trial. How do I find that, right?
So the processes. And importantly, people.
People will be the key part, and this is really the reason
why I'm at St. Jude, the amazing people that I found
there. I hope it answers. Thank you.
All right. That's a wrap, everybody. Thank you so much.
Thank you to our speakers. Thank you for being here.